sendo assim o botafogo não tem e aí ela
existe um jogador com vocês e estamos
agora a minha nova casa que comprei essa
aqui é é figura da malhação contratei
também está aqui mas vai ficar só
significa que a gabíno time você já deve
conhecer bem o time delas um tablet é
tamanha que o chimbinha
[Aplausos]
a gente tá aqui pra falar um pouquinho
pra vocês sobre sabe que música música
moderna sua vida à música pra você que
não sabe que tem de matar não curtos
love ambos já no curta com fone de
ouvido mais a música você não precisa tá
gostando dela você talvez houve estando
melhor faça um carro de som instrumental
seu ouvido a música de vocês gasista
estupro estupro é que a galera gosta da
pasta ocupada assim no piauí nunca tinha
feito pra estupra ética é engraçado é
que tu para estudar não foi estuprada no
mês de junho nec o estupro é tipo 'ah eu
peguei você querer mais até você chutar
estufa de fumo não é de muita pedra que
vai para o ar mas era música né é uma
coisa que acontece muito com as pessoas
querem é o seguinte vou citar o nome da
rua andaluzita mão machão que é de
homens nem toca tua música mano brown
tom rosa e verde no caso ela faça a
semana toda aqui é mesmo dia consecutivo
tem que parar tudo o que a música
manoel e 80 querer isso não é pra mim
acontece muito isso aí contou às vezes
eu estou andando nada assim do nada a
música que eu gosto que eu amo após o
que acontece um tio que tanto gosta e
infectou realmente demonstra alguma
situação que acontece contigo é que esse
legado tanto a música quanto pela balada
equipe está num lugar que não espera que
vai tocar música no campeonato como nós
a nossa tão barata com a música muita
música quem sabe né então e assim muita
música e depois não se essa música
atendeu é por isso então contar à amiga
que é muito difícil que ela mora no mato
grosso do sul
enquanto a gente está aí começa a tocar
uma música ai de louça e falou que é uma
coisa que é muito difícil falar com sua
amiga linda toca a música de vocês não
entram aquelas começar qualquer outra
música tipo assim 10 e champanhas e quem
és mi no piantella de maceió entender
por que a gente é engraçado ele começa a
fazer os vídeos certo sim como vocês
fazem muito tempo você se vê ou se
identifica com a música de jackson
hoje eu quero não assim graças à dupla
vencedora tenho costas música que fala
sem negócios em título em 30 metros
mesmo tentar bresser carney como dr de
uma garrafa de tequila eu achei propano
eu fosse sua e romântico é uma coisa que
você não sabe sobre mim mas eu adoro
essas músicas tipo foi tapa na bunda da
hp espera levantar romântica roda cenas
não mas que também gosta de música
romântica eu gostava mas que tipo de
local da área tudo que você que gosta de
dançar não gosto acho o boston a oficina
fazendo 6 3
brincando porque eu sei que é claro mas
eu gosto de música que eu gosto porque
eu tô problemas que só pergunto música
gospel no microblog fulano de tal a dar
todas as músicas
às vezes eu conheço um monte de frontal
com isso outra música de outro fã outra
musa de ouro a lei do nada se passando
com a música
um carro de som eu fico doido pra saber
que música aquela eu gosto só bela no
cantor não fazendo pra mim eu vou te
falar a palavra aceitávamos a face de
não se fazer qualquer música que eu faço
lá da hora é desinfetante divã galera a
palavra desinfetante
[Música]
a minha pelo tai chi joga gaza nesta
sexta 21 mandela bem a nação vizinha o
litro disse button ao chiado
o chile é para limpar o chão chão chão
a campanha o indiano the voice vamos lá
gente não faz a campanha mas ele aqui
que legal que você chega lá ninguém virá
a cadeira
a mostra vai ser o melhor campanha na
internet não foi o da partida do dia do
fábio junto ao mostrar uma gêmea sua
carne nem eu quero que você comente aqui
em baixo tá ligado nos como em casa o
que você qual a música que você mais
odeia não quero que o pensamento fica
véu mal quero ver o estrupo mendonça
comentei com a música você mais odeia e
o canal hbo e lutar se você não conhece
a faz curvas nêuta kit clique aqui ou
não tá dando um aspecto que não isso um
ataque quando a cadela da raça e se
esquece de dar uma olhada nos covers
total em tic tac é parte que lá é nóis
valeu que vai gostar de saber como é que
era naquele jóia que ajuda nós refere